Shure:  为什么写着原浆荞麦啤酒3元一罐
Shure: Why does it say raw buckwheat beer is 3 yuan a can...
Shure:  而打开冰箱却一罐啤酒都没有
Shure: ...but there's no beer in the fridge?
Shure:  为什么为什么
Shure: Why, why?
Shure:  不行
Shure: No way.
Shure:  配着这个音乐就哈哈哈就忍不住
Shure: With this music, I just can't stop laughing.
Lucia: 那简直是火葬场给碎了这歌听起来不是很
Lucia: That sounds like a crematorium, this song doesn't sound...
Shure:  你知道吗
Shure: You know what?
Shure:  我们保卫黄河
Shure: We defend the Yellow River.
Shure:  保卫华北
Shure: Defend North China.
Shure:  保卫全中国呵呵
Shure: Defend all of China, hehe
Jake: 哈哈你把这个杀二台电脑烧了
Jake: Haha, you burned the second computer
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure:  好多黄油啊
Shure: So much butter
Jake: 一个烟头打过去
Jake: Throw a cigarette butt over
Shure:  哦一会是不是要吃那什么来着
Shure: Oh, are we going to eat that thing later?
Shure:  我把麻将给卸了吧
Shure: Should I take apart the mahjong set?
Jake: 行啊可以
Jake: Sure, go ahead
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Alright
Shure:  麻将在哪
Shure: Where's the mahjong set?
Jake: 哎
Jake: Hey
Jake: 没灯了没灯了没灯了
Jake: No lights, no lights, no lights
Jake: 对啊对啊
Jake: Yeah, yeah
Lucia: 我的那根线在楼上还是楼下啊好像楼上
Lucia: Is my cable upstairs or downstairs? I think upstairs
Shure:  家人们
Shure: Guys
Shure:  麻将昨天放到哪里了
Shure: Where did we put the mahjong set yesterday?
Shure:  应该不会吧
Shure: It shouldn't be, right?
Tasha: 这里吧
Tasha: Here, I think
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah
Shure:  OK
Shure: OK
Shure:  来给家人们表演一个蟹麻酱
Shure: Let's perform a crab mayo for everyone
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Sure
Shure:  好吧
Shure: Alright
Katrina: 需要一个
Katrina: We need one
Jake: 充电宝是吧
Jake: A power bank, right?
Katrina: power bank
Katrina: Power bank
Shure: power bank
Shure: Power bank
Jake: 呃这个可以行驶哦
Jake: Uh, this can drive
Lucia: 你已经充满了
Lucia: It's already fully charged
Jake: 我可以插在电脑上
Jake: I can plug it into the computer
Tasha: 摁压
Tasha: Press
Lucia: 按一下它就开始出水
Lucia: Press it and water will come out
Lucia: 再按一下它就停一下
Lucia: Press again and it stops
Jake: 摁这那个
Jake: Press that one
Lucia: 嗯那个红点
Lucia: Yes, the red dot
Jake: 它要等吗
Jake: Does it need to wait?
Lucia: 不需要等
Lucia: No need to wait
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay
Lucia: 楼上那个不需要等
Lucia: The one upstairs doesn't need to wait
Shure:  筷子在哪
Shure: Where are the chopsticks?
Jake:  要插电是吧
Jake: Does it need to be plugged in?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Jake: 那我上楼接水
Jake: Then I'll go upstairs to get some water.
Choiszt: 筷子这有筷子吗
Choiszt: Are there any chopsticks here?
Lucia: 这没插电这有电吗
Lucia: Is this plugged in? Does it have power?
Shure:  这筷子昨天是刷了还是没刷
Shure: Were these chopsticks washed yesterday or not?
Lucia: 对要不你还是上楼吧
Lucia: Yes, why don't you go upstairs?
Jake: 好好好
Jake: Okay, okay, okay.
Jake: 一会他们收拾完房间
Jake: Once they finish tidying up the room,
Jake: 然后你们也收拾一下房间
Jake: Then you guys tidy up your room too.
Jake: 收拾完之后就带我们
Jake: After you're done, just tell us
Jake: 稍微讲一讲你们要干什么
Jake: Briefly what you plan to do.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 行吧我你们
Jake: Okay, I...
Tasha:你们出方案是吗
Tasha: Are you guys coming up with a plan?
Jake: 没有出发
Jake: Not yet.
Jake: 就是加一些环节
Jake: We're just adding some relaxation.
Jake: 然后吃火锅
Jake: And then we'll have hotpot.
Jake: 吃完火锅之后把礼物送掉
Jake: After hotpot, we'll give out the gifts.
Choiszt:  好
Choiszt: Okay.
Jake: 你好什么
Jake: What do you mean okay?
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Choiszt: 听着就很开心
Choiszt: Just hearing it makes me happy.
Nicous:  这感觉有点少了
Nicous: This seems a bit lacking.
Shure:  湿度还有一点
Shure: The humidity is still a bit high.
Jake: 我们还是到二楼吃火锅吧
Jake: Let's have the hotpot on the second floor.
Jake: 我们上去把桌子给搬搬中间去
Jake: We'll move the table to the middle up there.
Jake: 一楼确实乱了点，一点都吃不了
Jake: The first floor is really messy, can't eat here at all.
Nicous:  我帮你打麻将
Nicous: I'll help you with Mahjong.
Nicous:  慢三倍哈哈
Nicous: Three times slower, haha.
Jake: 哎你我我们帮帮我硕
Jake: Hey, you, can you help me out, Shure?
Shure:  哎
Shure: Hey.
Jake: 帮我们拍一张
Jake: Take a picture for us.
Shure:  拍什么
Shure: A picture of what?
Jake: 照
Jake: Just a photo.
Shure:  拍一张是吗哦
Shure: Take a photo, right? Okay.
Shure:  你们三个
Shure: You three.
Jake:对对联机
Jake: Yes, yes, online.
Jake: 还是黑1
Jake: Still black 1.
Shure: 14
Shure: 14.
Shure:  three v three v three
Shure: three v three v three
Jake: 呃摆拍摆拍一下
Jake: Uh, pose for a picture
Katrina: 我帮你们
Jake: 不要打麻将了
Jake: Don't play Mahjong
Choiszt:  哈哈哈要发给老板
Choiszt: Hahaha, send it to the boss
Shure:  什么时候打麻将啊
Shure: When are we playing Mahjong?
Shure:  对不是说有这个环节吗
Shure: Right, wasn't there supposed to be a Mahjong session?
Alice: Cheers cheers
Alice: Cheers, cheers
Jake: 那我就这样作为一个老板
Jake: As the boss, I...
Alice: 然后他们俩赶紧
Alice: Then they should hurry up
Shure:  你们得严肃的办公啊
Shure: You guys should work seriously
Shure:  你得一边喝着咖啡
Shure: You should be drinking coffee while working nonstop
Shure:  然后一边守着手里工作都不停
Shure: And keep working while holding it
Shure: 哎谢明珠脸没漏出来哎
Shure: Hey, Xie Mingzhu's face isn't showing
Shure:  对对对好好好
Shure: Yes, yes, good, good
Shure:  然后你再那个帅往右边侧一侧脸
Shure: Then, Choiszt, turn your face to the right a bit
Shure:  右右右
Shure: Right, right, right
Shure:  哎对然后再往后一点帅往后一点
Shure: Yes, then move back a bit, Choiszt, move back a bit
Katrina:  有一点像那个
Katrina: It looks a bit like that
Shure:  然后再往右一点帅脸往右侧一点
Shure: Then move to the right a bit, Choiszt, turn your face to the right
Shure:  OK OK
Shure: OK, OK
Jake: 就是上新闻里播不了的
Jake: This can't be broadcasted on the news
Shure: OK
Shure: OK OK
Shure: OK, OK
Katrina: 帅帅帅
Katrina: Handsome, handsome, handsome
Shure:  无敌先生
Shure: Mr. Invincible
Jake:无敌
Jake: Invincible
Nicous: 招呼一下招呼一下
Nicous: Say hello, say hello
Choiszt:  来这
Choiszt: Come here
Choiszt:  这个没拍全
Choiszt: This wasn't fully captured
Jake: 这个电脑少拍了
Jake: Some computers weren't captured
Jake: 少拍几台电脑啊
Jake: How many computers weren't captured?
Shure: 昂懂了懂了
Shure: Got it, got it
Choiszt:  你这个说广告
Choiszt: You mean this is an ad
Shure:  怎么摸鱼呢
Shure: How to slack off?
Shure:  好可以
Shure: Okay, got it
Jake: 这个一般是什么
Jake: What is this usually?
Jake: 创业劲头是吧
Jake: The entrepreneurial spirit, right?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes
Jake: 等到这个升值百亿的时候
Jake: When this company is worth billions
Jake: 这张照片
Jake: This photo
Shure:  然后就是雷总苗总
Shure: And then there's Mr. Lei and Mr. Miao
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah
Choiszt:  召回一下
Choiszt: Recall that
Jake: 这眼影盘比较贵
Jake: This eyeshadow palette is pretty expensive
Tasha: 我舍不得
Tasha: I can't bear to use it
Shure:  所以你没有看到我刚才给你发的视频
Shure: So you didn't see the video I sent you earlier
Shure:  在放安普
Shure: Playing Amp
Shure:  我很伤心
Shure: I'm really sad
Jake: 嘿嘿
Jake: Hehe
Jake: 你你的可能啊
Jake: Maybe yours
Jake: 你们俩在
Jake: You two are
Jake: 你们俩在互相传
Jake: You two are sharing
Jake: 哦哦哦来来来
Jake: Oh, oh, oh, come on
Jake: 打扫的
Jake: Cleaning
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure:  怎么切我歌呢
Shure: Why did you skip my song?
Katrina: 谁切了
Katrina: Who skipped it?
Shure:  哎很伤心
Shure: Ugh, I'm so sad
Shure:  还没满day
Shure: It's not even full day yet
Shure:  陪你走到Sunday呢
Shure: Supposed to accompany you till Sunday
Jake: 哎 40 放
Jake: Hey, 40, play it
Shure:  可以可以可以
Shure: Okay, okay, okay
Jake: 去吧
Jake: Go ahead
Jake: 可以
Jake: Okay
Lucia: 给搭把手啊
Lucia: Give me a hand
Shure: 好勒谢谢您
Shure: Sure, thank you
Katrina: 有厕所的垃圾没
Katrina: Is there trash from the bathroom?
Jake: 对门口有好多垃圾
Jake: Yeah, there's a lot of trash at the door
Jake: 就门后面
Jake: Just behind the door
Jake: 门后面垃圾是归谁管
Jake: Who's responsible for the trash behind the door?
Jake: 这些呃我们纸盒还有机会要吗
Jake: Do we still need these cardboard boxes?
Jake: 还挑一挑
Jake: Sort through them
Lucia: 呃纸盒有几个
Lucia: How many cardboard boxes are there?
Lucia: 我挑了确定不要的
Lucia: I sorted out the ones we definitely don't need
Jake: 哦哦哦对
Jake: Oh, oh, oh, right
Shure:  哎咱们
Shure: Hey, do we
Shure:  这有酱油来着吗
Shure: Have soy sauce here?
Tasha: 酱油没有
Tasha: No soy sauce
Shure:  民宿没
Shure: Does the B&B have
Shure:  自带点什么调料之类的
Shure: any condiments or something like that?
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Huh?
Shure:  民宿没自带点调料
Shure: The B&B doesn't have any condiments?
Shure:  什么的吗
Shure: Or what?
Shure: 叫什么
Shure: What's it called?
Shure:  水多了放糖
Shure: If there's too much water, add sugar.
Shure:  糖多了放水
Shure: If there's too much sugar, add water.
Jake: 哪个铁门
Jake: Which iron gate?
Shure:  这是哪个rapper
Shure: Which rapper is this?
Katrina: 这个歌是比较小众的 歌手
Katrina: This song is by a rather niche artist.
Shure: 叫什么
Shure: What's the name?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Huh?
Katrina: 这不是比较小众
Katrina: He's not very mainstream.
Shure:  是我问叫什么
Shure: I'm asking what's his name.
Shure:  这个人
Shure: This person.
Shure:  OK
Shure: OK.
Shure:  多少粉丝现在
Shure: How many fans does he have now?
Katrina: 昂在等一个小时
Katrina: Uh, waiting for an hour.
Shure:  网易云呢
Shure: What about on NetEase Cloud?
Katrina: 网易云啊
Katrina: NetEase Cloud, huh.
Shure:  觉得感觉可以买他点歌哎
Shure: I think we could buy some of his songs.
Katrina: 这人跟我们一样大八百
Katrina: This guy is around our age, about 800.
Shure:  我还买过好多比咱们小的
Shure: I have bought songs from many who are younger than us.
Katrina: 这是干啥哦这 麻酱
Katrina: What's this, oh, sesame paste.
Shure:  和麻酱
Shure: Mixed with sesame paste.
Shure:  那叫一个地道
Shure: That's what you call authentic.
Shure:  嘀嗒嘀嘀嗒嘀嗒嘀
Shure: Di da di di da di da di.
Nicous: 我曹这啥人
Nicous: Whoa, what kind of person is this?
Shure:  完了水加多了
Shure: Oh no, added too much water.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahaha.
Shure: 他说一直向北望总也望不住
Shure: He said he kept looking north but couldn't see anything.
Jake: 我拍了一个这个
Jake: I took a picture of this.
Katrina: 哇好厉害
Katrina: Wow, amazing.
Shure:  什么
Shure: What?
Nicous: 我马上就好了
Nicous: I'm almost done.
Shure:  可以
Shure: Alright.
Katrina: 咋两去看小狗吧
Katrina: Should we go see the puppies?
Jake: 现在可以去了你
Jake: You can go now.
Jake: 你插上电我们对齐就可以去
Jake: Plug it in, and once we align, we can go.
Shure:   歇好麻酱了
Shure: Rested well, the sesame paste is ready.
Shure:  但是麻酱是淡的
Shure: But the sesame paste is bland.
Shure:  咱们没有酱油
Shure: We don't have soy sauce.
Jake: 试着开机
Jake: Try turning it on.
Shure:  所以可以加点盐
Shure: So we can add some salt.
Jake: 我看看你的电帅
Jake: Let me check your electric handsome.
Shure:  我的一直在脸上
Shure: Mine is always on my face.
Shure:  所以他一定是100%
Shure: So it must be 100%.
Lucia: 我觉得可以现在已经百分之十三了
Lucia: I think it's already at 13%.
Jake: 好嘞
Jake: Okay.
Shure:  没有多余的
Shure: No extras.
Lucia: 可以了
Lucia: It's fine.
Shure:  皮套之类的东西吗
Shure: Things like leather cases?
Jake: 好的
Jake: Got it.
Lucia: 多余的什么
Lucia: Extra what?
Shure:  皮套之类的
Shure: Leather cases and such.
Lucia: 什么叫皮套
Lucia: What's a leather case?
Shure:  就是扎头发那种
Shure: Like those for tying hair.
Lucia: 哦皮筋啊
Lucia: Oh, hair ties.
Shure:  对皮筋
Shure: Yeah, hair ties.
Jake: 呀你这鞋还是同款的呀
Jake: Wow, your shoes are still matching!
Jake: 怎么做到的啊
Jake: How did you do it?
Shure: 啊 也不是就是买了点彩虹元素
Shure: Uh, not really, just bought some rainbow elements.
Shure:  但是本人并不是的
Shure: But I'm not really into that myself.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure:  我要把头发扎起来太长了
Shure: I need to tie my hair up, it's too long.
Choiszt: 现在能做吗
Choiszt: Can we do it now?
Jake: 呼这糖怎么办
Jake: Phew, what about this sugar?
Jake: 给他溶啊
Jake: Melt it, right?
Jake: 倒掉是吧
Jake: Throw it away, huh?
Jake: 倒了
Jake: Threw it.
Shure:  这还有两个真好
Shure: There are still two more, great.
Katrina: 他帮我了吗
Katrina: Did he help me?
Jake: 呃我看一下
Jake: Uh, let me check.
Jake: 问一下
Jake: I'll ask.
Jake: 喂
Jake: Hey.
Jake: 扔否
Jake: Throw it?
Jake: 扔吗
Jake: Throw it away?
Lucia: 什么
Lucia: What?
Jake: 这些小包要不要扔
Jake: Do we throw these little bags away?
Jake: 收拾好了
Jake: All packed up.
Katrina:  走不走看狗去
Katrina: Let's go check on the dog.
Katrina:  然后要回来搞搞搞饭了
Katrina: Then we need to come back and start cooking.
Shure: 走走
Shure: Let's go.
Jake: 对去看狗吧
Jake: Yeah, let's go see the dog.
Katrina:  他在吗
Katrina: Is he there?
Katrina:  他俩去吗
Katrina: Are they going?
Katrina:  你们俩去吗
Katrina: Are you two going?
Katrina:  你俩去吗
Katrina:  阿姨卫生间洗手间倒了吧
Katrina: Auntie, did you clean the bathroom?
Katrina:  啊OK哦
Katrina: Ah, okay.
Katrina:  哦
Katrina: Oh.
Lucia: 对楼上那个洗手间也换一下可以吗
Lucia: Yeah, can you also change the upstairs bathroom?
Katrina:  好谢谢啊
Katrina: Okay, thanks.
Lucia: 哦也行
Lucia: Oh, that works.
Shure:  这箱子我们留着还有点用
Shure: Let's keep this box, we might still need it.
Shure:  谢谢啊谢谢您
Shure: Thanks, thank you.
Jake: 搁哪呢
Jake: Where is it?
Tasha: 我没电了我现在停 我没停啊我现在停
Tasha: I'm out of battery. I'm stopping now. Oh, I didn't stop, now I stopped.
Lucia: 啊可以的
Lucia: Ah, that's fine.
Lucia: 主要就是
Lucia: Mainly just...
Lucia: 主要就是那个垃圾桶
Lucia: Mainly just the trash can.
Lucia: 收拾一下就行了
Lucia: Just need to clean it up.
Lucia: 呃这边的这些箱纸箱吗
Lucia: Uh, these cardboard boxes here?
Jake:研究完了
Jake: Done researching.
Jake: 研究出的ID
Jake: The ID is figured out.
Jake: ID也出来了
Jake: The ID is ready.
Alice: 呃一个比较杂乱的这也是
Alice: Uh, it's a bit messy too.
Katrina:  应该是外卖垃圾
Katrina: Must be takeout trash.
Lucia: 对都不要吧
Lucia: Yeah, don't need any of it.
Lucia: 对对然后这个你知道就是
Lucia: Yeah, and you know...
Katrina:  嗯那种就是小玩偶
Katrina: Uh-huh, those little dolls.
Katrina:  然后他可以抱在那个
Katrina: They can be put on the...
Katrina:  就是这种门把手上
Katrina: Like on the door handles.
Katrina:  那个叫其他有几个我们好像还没
Katrina: There are a few more we haven't...
Katrina:  就是包括你有一个这样的圆柱的那个
Katrina: Including that cylindrical one you have.
Lucia: 叫什么花花圈
Lucia: What's it called, wreath?
Lucia: 这边这些是什么关键词
Lucia: What are the keywords here?
Tasha: 你可以试着搜类似的然后看有没有
Tasha: You can try searching for similar ones and see if there are any.
Lucia:画画圈我是
Lucia: Wreath, I am...
Shure: 哦我 前两天看那个
Shure:  一个表情包就啪啪圈的图然然后
Katrina:  就还有那种可以
Katrina:  就是背书包上可以放在你书包上的
Shure:  然后说
Shure:  这这是我们小时候玩的最早的SM
Shure:  哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina:  走吧咱么去不去
Jake:对齐对齐
Lucia: 哎咱门口就是
Lucia: 那那些箱子是已经收拾过的吗
Lucia: 讲好了吗
Shure: 应该讲好了
Shure: 有点稀了但是没事问题不大
Shure: 本来就是水多了放盐盐多了
Katrina:  外卖带麻将还是
Shure: 是的
Tasha: 我不吃油碟吃不了
Shure: 放了
Tasha: 你吃油碟还是
Tasha: Are you using the oil dip or...
Shure: 放盐了，其实
Shure: Just add some salt, actually.
Lucia: 行行行我买油碟
Lucia: Alright, alright, I'll buy the oil dip.
Shure:  本来是应该加酱油或者生抽来调那个咸味
Shure: Usually, you should add soy sauce or light soy sauce to adjust the saltiness.
Alice:味极鲜
Alice: Umami soy sauce.
Katrina:  昨天没买酱油
Katrina: We didn't buy soy sauce yesterday.
Shure: 差不多就这样
Shure: It's pretty much like that.
Katrina:  哎无所谓
Katrina: Oh, whatever.
Katrina: 但我不吃麻酱
Katrina: But I don't eat sesame paste.
Shure:  你们怎么私闯我的房间呢
Shure: How did you guys break into my room?
Katrina: gogo
Katrina: Go, go.
Choiszt: 谢斌竹隐犯了
Choiszt: The gold pearl is printed backwards.
Shure: 什么隐犯了
Shure: What's printed backwards?
Choiszt: 就是能收到不
Choiszt: The "p" can you receive it or not?
Shure:  你要你要你要
Shure: You want it, you want it, you want it.
Shure:  在我这里面开
Shure: Open it within mine.
Choiszt: 就就是一个字骗他他能理你了
Choiszt: Just say one word, trick him, and he'll respond to you.
Shure: 我理解不了
Shure: I don't get it.
Katrina: 要走赶紧走吧
Katrina: If you want to leave, leave quickly.
Choiszt: 哎你这把头发扎起来还是可以的
Choiszt: Hey, tying your hair up like that is actually fine.
Jake: 你这有电
Jake: Do you have electricity here?
Shure: 好好好嗯是
Shure: Okay okay, yes.
Katrina:  很艺术你看那画家的感觉
Katrina: It's so artistic, look at the painter's vibe.
Choiszt: 我觉得你这个头发很日式我感觉
Choiszt: I think your hairstyle is very Japanese.
Shure:  霓虹机
Shure: Neon machine.
Shure:  乌鸡洞
Shure: Uji cave.
Shure:  走吗
Shure: Shall we go?
Katrina: 走吗
Katrina: Shall we go?
Katrina:  溜一圈回来
Katrina: Let's take a walk around.
Katrina:  今天还没出去凑气
Katrina: We haven't gone out today to get some air.
Jake: 开一下
Jake: Open it.
Shure: 咱俩去走
Shure: Let's go.
Katrina:  他俩上厕所要
Katrina: They're going to the bathroom.
Shure:  哪有人上厕所啊
Shure: Who's going to the bathroom?
Katrina:  不知道啊
Katrina: I don't know.
Nicous: 咋了
Choiszt: 没事不用不用走吧走帮我看着点
Choiszt: It's fine, no need to worry. Let's go, but keep an eye on it for me.
Katrina:  两小时衣服就干了
Katrina: The clothes will dry in two hours.
Katrina:  我靠这大太阳爽了
Katrina: Wow, this big sun is great.
Shure: 我靠
Shure: Wow.
Katrina:  我来帮他采一点户外的景开
Katrina: I'll help him capture some outdoor scenes.
Katrina:  开辟一些新地图
Katrina: Let's explore some new areas.
Katrina:  你记得是往左还是往右吗
Katrina: Do you remember if it was left or right?
Shure: 我记得
Shure: I remember.
Shure:  从那边对走呗
Shure: It's that way, let's go.
Katrina:  这哎
Katrina: This way.
Shure: yes
Shure: Yes.
Katrina:  那有只小猫咪
Katrina: There's a little cat.
Katrina:  哎呀书包里的猫条还在
Katrina: Oh, the cat treats in my backpack are still here.
Katrina:  宿舍楼下有一只吃的巨肥
Katrina: There's a really fat one under the dorm building.
Katrina: 就好像跟老虎一样然后嘴巴还歪
Katrina: It's like a tiger, and its mouth is crooked.
Katrina: 反正他可小了
Katrina: Anyway, it's really small.
Shure: 你们随身会带猫条
Shure: You carry cat treats with you?
Katrina:  因为学校里有很多猫
Katrina: Because there are a lot of cats at school.
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
Katrina: 哇两只
Katrina: Wow, two of them.
Katrina:  昨天只看一只在下半夜
Katrina: Yesterday, I only saw one in the middle of the night.
Shure:  是这边把
Shure: It's this way, right?
Shure:  哦他是一筒
Shure: Oh, it's a barrel.
Shure:  一直来一直哇
Shure: It keeps coming, wow.
Katrina: 头哎
Katrina: Head, oh.
Shure: 太屌了你给人 吓走了
Shure: That was awesome, you scared them away.
Katrina:  别这么吓人吧
Katrina: Don't be so scary.
Katrina:  看一下别的房间怎么样
Katrina: Let's check out the other rooms.
Shure:  是这边吧
Shure: Is it this way?
Katrina:  我不知道啊
Katrina: I don't know.
Katrina:  好像是这边吧
Katrina: I think it's this way.
Shure: 不知道啊
Shure: Not sure.
Katrina:  是不是是不是这出去然后右边去
Katrina: Is it this way and then turn right?
Shure:  不是我们操不是这边
Shure: No, it's not this way.
Shure:  那是那边
Shure: It's over there.
Katrina:  我们就不说我们走错了
Katrina: Let's just not say we got lost.
Katrina:  我说我们出来遛遛
Katrina: I'll say we just took a walk.
Shure:  提前呼吸一下新鲜空气啊
Shure: To get some fresh air early.
Shure:  果然是那边
Shure: It's definitely over there.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure:  完了追不上哎
Shure: Damn, can't catch up.
Shure: 它们逃
Shure: They're escaping.
Katrina: 我们追
Katrina: We chase.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Shure: 它们逃我们追它们插翅难飞
Shure: They escape, we chase, they can't fly away.
Katrina:  每天晚上感觉那个还有好多事情要多要给那么多充电宝充电还有那么多摄像头还有眼镜也要充电还要导数据感觉他一个脑子掰成了好多
Katrina: Every night it feels like there are so many things to do, charging all those power banks, cameras, and even glasses, and transferring data. It's like his brain is split into many parts.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yeah.
Shure:  是PhD的脑袋跟我们的
Shure: A PhD's brain is different from ours.
Katrina:  每一个脑细胞都能单独的那种
Katrina: Every brain cell can work independently.
Shure: 确实不像我们就只能混成一坨屎来工作
Shure: Unlike us, we can only work like a pile of crap.
Katrina: 混成一坨屎一件事还做不好
Katrina: A pile of crap that can't even do one thing right.
Shure: 就是
Shure: Exactly.
Shure:  我们就是单核单线成
Shure: We're single-core, single-threaded.
Katrina: 哇战斗机
Katrina: Wow, a fighter jet.
Shure:  这不是乱看哈哈哈
Shure: Don't just look around, haha.
Shure:  这容易被抓起来的
Shure: You might get caught easily.
Katrina: 这花香当时在天津的时候天津也有很多这种花
Katrina: The flowers, back in Tianjin, there were many of these flowers too.
Shure: 紫藤
Shure: Wisteria.
Shure: 永远的紫荆花就为了我们我们工作室的
Shure: The everlasting Bauhinia, just for our studio.
Katrina: 你们那个工作室一般流程是什么就是看哪个歌比较火然后去把他版权
Katrina: What's the usual process in your studio? Do you look for popular songs and then buy their rights?
Shure: 对买下来
Shure: Yeah, buy them.
Katrina: 一般多少钱
Katrina: How much usually?
Katrina:  谈商务吗就是
Katrina: Do you negotiate?
Shure: 对谈商务合同不是
Shure: Yeah, negotiate the contract.
Katrina: 什么时候去对接
Katrina: When do you connect with them?
Shure: 一般都是经纪人 或者是制作公司
Shure: It's usually handled by agents or production companies.
Katrina: 那你们这样的样会不会可以就接触到一些明星
Katrina: So, does that mean you get to meet some celebrities?
Shure: 啊姜云成前两天还过来了呢
Shure: Oh, Jiang Yun came by just a few days ago.
Katrina: 哇
Katrina: Wow.
Shure: 我们云城就是他 一直我们就有合作的他的好多就一半的歌吧都是跟我们弄的
Shure: Yeah, we collaborate with Yun Cheng often. Many of his songs, maybe half of them, we've worked on together.
Katrina: 今天不能喝咖啡了昨天喝两杯
Katrina: I can't have coffee today. I had two cups yesterday.
Shure: 你们在干嘛你们在撸狗吗
Shure: What are you guys doing? Petting the dog?
Shure: 你方便吗 昂
Shure: Is it convenient for you now?
Katrina:  这么亲人的吗
Katrina: Is it really that friendly?
Shure:  我可以扒你的裤子吗
Shure: Can I pull your pants down?
Katrina: 这是边牧吧
Katrina: Is this a Border Collie?
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yes.
Katrina: 哎他舔我
Katrina: Hey, he's licking me.
Katrina: 我也可想养只小狗来着我妈不行不能咬我的线生命之线断电了我的赛博生命就不存在了
Katrina: I've always wanted a puppy, but my mom says no. If it bites my cables, my cyber life would be over.
Katrina: 他叫什么名字
Katrina: What's his name?
Shure:  哎
Shure: Hey.
Katrina:  这么大应该是几个月吧
Katrina: He's so big, he must be a few months old.
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: Oh.
Choiszt: 他也不叫
Choiszt: He doesn't even bark.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Shure: 唤醒他一些
Shure: Wake him up a bit.
Katrina: 他他的牙长的呀
Katrina: His teeth are growing in.
Choiszt: 两斤
Choiszt: Two pounds.
Shure: 他怎么不搭理我呢是我语法错误太多了吗
Shure: Why is he ignoring me? Is my grammar too bad?
Katrina: 你的狗语不太对
Katrina: Your dog language is off.
Choiszt: 一句话三个语法错
Choiszt: Three grammatical errors in one sentence.
Shure: 哎呀完了我的生命线断了
Shure: Oh no, my lifeline is broken.
Shure:  那些不该看的地方都被我们看光了
Shure: We've seen everything we shouldn't have seen.
Katrina:  小孩子不懂
Katrina: Kids don't understand.
Shure:  你说谁不懂
Shure: Who are you calling clueless?
Katrina: 把他这样克进来
Katrina: Bring him in like this.
Shure: 你不要额用你的钉钉对着我们好吗
Shure: Don't point your finger at us, okay?
Katrina: 青涩
Katrina: Naive.
Katrina: 我家之前养了一只不懂得来时把我妈臭的
Katrina: We used to have one at home, and it didn't understand, so it made my mom mad.
Katrina: 长牙了吗
Katrina: Are his teeth growing in?
Shure: 他长了然他咬你一口就知道了
Shure: Yeah, if he bites you, you'll know.
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Ouch.
Shure: 本来我们还有参加一个比赛来着会的
Shure: We were supposed to participate in a competition.
Katrina:  什么大四了还参加
Katrina: What, you're a senior and still competing?
Shure: 乐队的比赛
Shure: It's a band competition.
Katrina: 可以啊知道呀
Katrina: Sure, I know.
Katrina: 歌直接网易云下
Katrina: Download the song directly from NetEase Cloud.
Choiszt: 你就当鼓手是吧
Choiszt: So you're gonna be the drummer, right?
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina: 多帅啊
Katrina: So cool.
Choiszt: 就是
Choiszt: Exactly.
Katrina: 不是这样我好不斯文
Katrina: If not, I wouldn't be so refined.
Shure: 就是
Shure: Exactly.
Shure: 会了你可以全身 拍然后给他打个码看着会诡异一些
Shure: If you know how, you can film the whole body and blur it out, it might look a bit weird.
Katrina: 你倒是考虑周到
Katrina: You really think things through.
Shure:  就保护狗丝
Shure: Just protecting the doggo.
Katrina: 刚开始的小狗就是是不是的训练一下不准咬人是不是
Katrina: At first, you have to train the puppy not to bite people, right?
Choiszt: 对
Choiszt: Right.
Katrina: 那就是他如果咬了就打他
Katrina: So if it bites, you just punish it.
Choiszt: 对他这个长大打他就不疼了
Choiszt: Yeah, but when it grows up, hitting won't hurt it anymore.
Shure:  边牧吗
Shure: Is it a Border Collie?
Shure:  叫什么七八岁讨狗嫌是吗
Shure: What is it, around seven or eight years old and still a nuisance?
Choiszt: 也不拆家也不咬人也不叫
Choiszt: It doesn't destroy the house, doesn't bite people, and doesn't bark.
Jake: 你不用像我这么慌
Jake: You don't have to be as panicked as me.
Choiszt: 就这么大对小时候就这么小买回来的时候就这么小
Choiszt: It was this small when I bought it, just a tiny little thing.
Choiszt: 这算什么颜色 咖啡色
Choiszt: What color is this? Brown?
Lucia: AI是不是收集到了一些很神奇的数据
Lucia: Did the AI collect some amazing data?
Katrina:  又咬又咬
Katrina: Biting again and again.
Shure: 咋不整个二锅头呢我靠
Shure: Why not just get some Erguotou, damn.
Shure: 他又看一些不该看的东西
Shure: He's looking at things he shouldn't be.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 你怎么这么喜欢咬东西你为什么喜欢咬东西啊
Shure: Why do you like biting things so much? Why do you like biting things?
Shure:  较力
Shure: Strength.
Shure:  与公牛较力
Shure: Competing with the bull.
Shure: 哎呦这串不能要
Shure: Oh no, can't have this string.
Shure:   321倒
Shure: 3, 2, 1, fall.
Shure:  什么
Shure: What?
Shure: 我可以砸你的叮叮不
Shure: Can I smash your ding-ding?
Shure:  好你把你手机拿拿远点
Shure: Okay, hold your phone further away.
Shure:  别砸着手机
Shure: Don’t smash the phone.
Shure: 耶
Shure: Yay.
Shure:  差太多了
Shure: Too far off.
Shure: 3太危险了
Shure: 3 is too dangerous.
Shure: 我们每人都挂个尿袋
Shure: Each of us should carry a urine bag.
Shure: 把我们尿袋咬断了就完了
Shure: If it bites through our urine bags, we're done for.
Shure: 这什么狗
Shure: What kind of dog is this?
Shure:  这这渣男就是防他的是吗
Shure: So, this scumbag is just protecting himself, right?
Choiszt: 得物买便宜还是淘宝
Choiszt: Is it cheaper to buy from Dewu or Taobao?
Shure:  都对比一下他不一定
Shure: Compare both, it's not certain.
Shure: 哎呀你这儿也能加一张也是太牛逼了
Shure: Wow, you can add one here too, that's awesome.
Shure:  哦咱们学校的精品店开了是吗
Shure: Oh, our school's boutique opened, right?
Shure:  叫自由制造
Shure: It's called Free Manufacturing.
Shure:  哎呦太土了这个名字
Shure: Oh my, what a tacky name.
Choiszt: 哪个精品店
Choiszt: Which boutique?
Shure:  沙不是那个吸土城那个
Shure: Isn't it the one near Xi Tu Cheng?
Shure:  就是洗发房洗头房旁边那个
Shure: It's the one next to the hair salon.
Shure: 不是发廊旁边那个
Shure: No, it's the one next to the barbershop.
Choiszt: 那不商城吗
Choiszt: Isn't that a mall?
Shure: 好像改了
Shure: It seems like it was changed.
Choiszt: 麦杂物杂货什么的吗
Choiszt: Does it sell miscellaneous items?
Shure:  就是卖咱们一些文创周边的
Shure: It sells some cultural and creative products.
Shure:  你要干嘛
Shure: What are you doing?
Shure:  我真的害怕他咬我的线
Shure: I'm really afraid it will bite my cable.
Shure:  哎我先回去了拜拜
Shure: Hey, I'm heading back now, bye.
Shure: 我不知道密码
Shure: I don't know the password.
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure:  密码多少
Shure: What's the password?
Shure:  嫂子开门
Shure: Sis, open the door.
Shure:  我是我哥
Shure: It's me, your brother.
Shure:  怎么又突然多了几个碗啊
Shure: Why are there suddenly more bowls?
Lucia: 可能是桌上刚收过去的
Lucia: Maybe they were just cleared from the table.
Lucia: 这这剩的这个
Lucia: This leftover...
Lucia: 反正碗都要洗了
Lucia: Anyway, the bowls need to be washed.
Lucia: 要把它倒了
Lucia: You need to dump it out.
Shure: 好的
Shure: Okay.
Shure:  你们早上是蘸白糖吃的吗
Shure: Did you guys dip in sugar for breakfast?
Lucia: 对哎呀妈呀
Lucia: Yes, oh my god.
Lucia: 这个充电线
Lucia: This charging cable...
Shure: 好 我来了我来了
Shure: Okay, I'm coming, I'm coming.
Lucia: 是的
Lucia: Yes.
Choiszt: 这个感觉也就30度还有
Choiszt: It feels like it's only 30 degrees or so.
Shure: 绝了
Shure: Amazing.
Choiszt:  主要还没加那个盐
Choiszt: Mainly, we haven't added the salt.
Shure:  加了点但加了不多
Shure: Added a bit, but not much.
Shure:  我不知道多少
Shure: I don't know how many.
Shure:  那些那些没有
Shure: Those, those are not available.
Shure:  腐乳什么的没有
Shure: No fermented bean curd.
Choiszt: 但不会调
Choiszt: But I don't know how to mix it.
Shure:  老北京二八酱是吧
Shure: Old Beijing 28 sauce, right?
Shure:  都怕有人不吃什么的
Shure: Everyone's afraid someone won't eat it.
Shure:  可以美团现在送一点是来得及的
Shure: You can order some on Meituan now, it should be in time.
Shure:  你美团点一下
Shure: Just order on Meituan.
Shure:  要不
Shure: Or...
Shure:  腐乳和韭菜花
Shure: Fermented bean curd and chive flower.
Shure:  这俩
Shure: These two.
Shure:  啊点吗
Shure: Ah, should we order?
Jake: 不回来了吗
Jake: Not coming back?
Shure: 没就
Shure: No, just...
Shure: 你好
Shure: Hello.
Shure: 有没有一点人肤感
Shure: Do you feel a bit of human skin touch?
Shure:  人肤感就是
Shure: Human skin touch is...
Jake:什么东西
Jake: What is that?
Shure:  人肤感就是人妻感和人夫感
Shure: Human skin touch is the feeling of being a wife or husband.
Jake:人夫
Jake: Husband?
Shure:  对
Shure: Yes.
Jake:学到一些很难反应的东西
Jake: Learning some really hard to understand things.
Shure: cost husband
Shure: Cost husband.
Shure: style感feeling yeah
Shure: Style feeling, yeah.
Shure: feeling of host husband
Shure: Feeling of host husband.
Shure: 我去楼上吃饭一会是吗
Shure: Should I go upstairs to eat for a while?
Jake: 去布置布置
Jake: Go decorate.
Jake:拖桌子去吧
Jake: Go move the tables.
Shure: 可以
Shure: Okay.
Alice:为啥一看淘宝就困
Alice: Why do I feel sleepy when I look at Taobao?
Lucia: 要不然上面凳子就不够了
Lucia: Otherwise, there won't be enough chairs upstairs.
Jake:现在几点
Jake: What time is it now?
Shure: 现在快6点了吧
Shure: It's almost 6 o'clock, right?
Shure: 应该 5:46差不多了
Shure: Should be around 5:46.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Jake:这怎么还开着
Jake: Why is this still on?
Jake:这亮灯啥
Jake: This light.
Shure: 一些红外信号吧
Shure: Some kind of infrared signal.
Lucia: 我又把这凳子给搬进来了
Lucia: I brought this chair back in again.
Shure: 是的，可以
Shure: That's moderate.
Lucia: 要不然攒一会不够123456
Lucia: Or else, if we save up for a bit, it won't be enough.
Shure: Monday和你走到Sunday
Shure: just do it just you
Shure: Just do it, just you.
Lucia: 这灯要不就把它放这这样转过来
Lucia: How about we put this lamp here and turn it around?
Lucia: 因为咱接下来两天还要练舞的话
Lucia: Since we have to practice dancing for the next two days.
Lucia: 那他就可以一直在这打着对吧
Lucia: It can stay here, right?
Lucia: 这个搬一点吃饭用
Lucia: Move this a bit for eating.
Shure: 要不插到花盆里
Shure: Or we can stick it in the flowerpot.
Jake:外观不够高
Jake: It doesn't look tall enough.
Jake:正好有一个什么东西
Jake: There happens to be something...
Jake:就是这都不行
Jake: But this won't work.
Jake:这样的都不行
Jake: This won't work either.
Shure: 这样
Shure: Like this.
Shure: 然后放
Shure: And then put it...
Shure: 放到放到放到这个这这上面就正好
Shure: Put it, put it on top of this, it'll be just right.
Shure: 应该是吧
Shure: Should be, right?
Shure: 哎呦不行
Shure: Oh no, it won't work.
Jake:再多一点或者硬一点的东西
Jake: Something a bit more or harder.
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This one.
Lucia: 把它翻过来然后
Lucia: Flip it over and then...
Shure: 那也不够高啊主要是
Shure: But it's not tall enough, mainly.
Lucia: 翻过来扣在这上面
Lucia: Flip it over and place it on top.
Jake:翻过来放在下面
Jake: Flip it over and put it underneath.
Lucia: 哦然后在上面再垫个纸
Lucia: Oh, and then put a piece of paper on top.
Lucia: 那估计还行
Lucia: That should work.
Lucia: 这里面有没有垃圾
Lucia: Is there any trash in here?
Shure: 来我来
Shure: Let me do it.
Shure: 红线划过深层
Shure: The red line cuts deep.
Lucia: 哇这个这这个
Lucia: Wow, this, this...
Lucia: 这个空调怎么关啊
Lucia: How do you turn off this air conditioner?
Lucia: 这上面吹的好冷
Lucia: It's blowing so cold up here.
Shure: 喊他关他就关了
Shure: Just tell it to turn off and it will.
Lucia: 真的吗语音控制的
Lucia: Really? Voice control?
Shure: 这不是这是电视遥控器
Shure: No, this is the TV remote.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Jake:在哪啊
Jake: Where is it?
Shure: 这儿呢这儿呢
Shure: Over here, over here.
Shure: 我们一会可能会热
Shure: We might get hot later.
Shure: 所以一会再开对
Shure: So we'll turn it back on later.
Lucia: 一会要上来煮火锅的话再开
Lucia: If we're going to have hotpot later, we can turn it back on.
Jake:是吗啊
Jake: Really?
Shure: 竖竖向是吗
Shure: Vertically, right?
Jake:对吧
Jake: Right?
Shure: 可以
Shure: Okay.
Jake:嗯来
Jake: Yeah, come on.
Lucia: 要帮忙吗
Lucia: Need any help?
Shure: 一二哎
Shure: One, two, hey.
Jake:暂暂且不要
Jake: Not for now.
Jake:可能就要了
Jake: Maybe soon.
Lucia: 感觉你们俩小心
Lucia: Be careful, you two.
Shure: 我们碰到什么了
Shure: Did we bump into something?
Jake:果然还是要帮忙
Jake: Turns out we do need help.
Lucia: 碰到这个
Lucia: Bumped into this.
Jake:继续吧
Jake: Keep going.
Shure: 你的屁股蹭到了是吗
Shure: Did your butt hit it?
Jake:这个地方夹到
Jake: This part got stuck.
Shure: 啊我以为是臀部太翘了
Shure: Ah, I thought your butt was too big.
Shure: 好差不多差不多
Shure: Alright, almost done.
Shure: 然后煮火锅时候大家把门关好
Shure: And when we're making hotpot, make sure to close the door.
Shure: 不然话熏的屋里都是那个味
Shure: Otherwise, the smell will fill the room.
Jake:对是的
Jake: Yeah, exactly.
Lucia: 那个就先暂且这样吧
Lucia: Let's leave it like this for now.
Jake:挺好来摆桌子
Jake: Great, let's set the table.
Shure: 外瑞good
Shure: Very good.
Jake:正好吧
Jake: Perfect, right?
Lucia: 椅子有6个
Lucia: There are six chairs.
Shure: 啊上午的时候桌子没擦
Shure: Ah, the table wasn't wiped this morning.
Shure: 要不擦一下
Shure: Should we wipe it?
Lucia: 这个这个腿每次都会掉下来吗
Lucia: Does this leg fall off every time?
Shure: 他是吊脚脚
Shure: It's a dangling leg.
Shure: 没问题
Shure: No problem.
Shure: 我们 可以上楼了
Shure: We can go upstairs now.
Shure: 带着一把凳子
Shure: Bring a stool.
Alice:带个板凳可以吗
Alice: Can I bring a stool?
Shure: 对带个凳子
Shure: Yes, bring a stool.
Shure: (歌词)Monday和你走到Sunday
Lucia: 现在都上去吗
Lucia: Are we all going up now?
Shure: 来吧我们摆锅摆菜准备开始
Shure: Come on, let's set up the pot and the ingredients and get started.
Alice:厕所有人吗
Alice: Is someone in the bathroom?
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: No idea.
Shure: 没有吧
Shure: I don't think so.
Tasha: 应该没有吧
Tasha: There shouldn't be, right?
Shure: 没有咱们都在
Shure: No, we are all here.
Shure: 然后那个那谁还在咖啡厅
Shure: And that guy is still in the café.
Shure: 其他都回来了
Shure: Everyone else is back.
Tasha: 上面怎么这么冷
Tasha: Why is it so cold upstairs?
Lucia: 因为之前空调一直开着
Lucia: Because the air conditioning was on before.
Shure: 刚开空调然后现在关了
Shure: The air conditioner was just turned off.
Shure: 这锁是坏的
Shure: This lock is broken.
Shure: 但是我们不会进的
Shure: But we won't go in.
Lucia: 那个锁是坏的
Lucia: That lock is broken.
Lucia: 这锁还是好的
Lucia: This lock is still good.
Lucia: 左边这锁好
Lucia: The lock on the left is good.
Lucia: 所以大家在这里上洗手间的时候
Lucia: So when everyone uses the restroom here,
Lucia: 要养成先敲门的习惯
Lucia: You should get into the habit of knocking first.
Alice:我以为是
Alice: I thought it was...
Shure: 真的没人
Shure: There's really no one.
Shure: 没有
Shure: No one.
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Oh my.
Shure: 不至于神经兮兮
Shure: No need to be so paranoid.
Lucia: 哦这有牛奶锅
Lucia: Oh, there's a milk pot here.
Lucia: 这是他这带的
Lucia: Is this his?
Lucia: 还是咱们的呀
Lucia: Or ours?
Shure: 这是我的咖啡壶
Shure: This is my coffee pot.
Lucia: 当我没说哈哈哈
Lucia: Never mind, haha.
Lucia: 虽然没坏但是没有纸
Lucia: Although it's not broken, there is no paper.
Shure: 嗯可以
Shure: Yeah, it's fine.
Shure: hello
Shure: Hello.
Shure: nice to meet you
Shure: Nice to meet you.
Shure: 往上拿东西吧
Shure: Let's take things upstairs.
Lucia: 这个都拿上去
Lucia: Take all of this upstairs.
Shure: 都拿上去吧
Shure: Take everything upstairs.
Shure: 这桌子没擦
Shure: This table hasn't been wiped.
Shure: 所以可能有点脏
Shure: So it might be a bit dirty.
Shure: 得稍微擦一下把
Shure: We need to wipe it a bit.
Lucia: 我已经拿出来了
Lucia: I've already taken it out.
Tasha: 还有东西要拿吗
Tasha: Is there anything else to take?
Tasha: 我就问肉
Tasha: I'm just asking about the meat.
Lucia: 啊就是火锅用的东西
Lucia: Oh, it's the stuff for hotpot.
Tasha: 对对
Tasha: Right, right.
Lucia: 基本上可以都拿上去
Lucia: We can basically take everything upstairs.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 也是个沉默的男人
Shure: He's a quiet guy too.
Tasha: 还有蒜蒜
Tasha: There's also garlic.
Shure: 蒜
Shure: Garlic?
Shure: 蒜需要拿吗
Shure: Do we need to bring the garlic?
Shure: 应该不用吧
Shure: Probably not, right?
Tasha: 要不要把锅拿上去
Tasha: Should we take the pot upstairs?
Shure: 要的哪个国主侯国
Shure: Which pot are you talking about?
Tasha: 就在这个底下
Tasha: The one underneath here.
Shure: 哦这有鸳鸯锅
Shure: Oh, there's a yin-yang pot.
Shure: 我靠
Shure: Wow.
Shure: 牛逼啊
Shure: That's awesome.
Shure: 然后电磁卢
Shure: And an induction cooker.
Tasha: 哎有两个鸳鸯锅
Tasha: Oh, there are two yin-yang pots.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yep.
Tasha: 正好要两个呢
Tasha: We need both of them.
Tasha: 因为不是桌子很大吗
Tasha: Because the table is so big, right?
Shure: 其实一个也差不多
Shure: Actually, one should be enough.
Shure: 主要底料没有那么多
Shure: We don't have that much base seasoning.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Shure: 牛油底料很多
Shure: We have a lot of butter base.
Shure: 但是清汤的和菌汤的只有一个
Shure: But only one clear broth and one mushroom broth.
Tasha: 清汤的一个
Tasha: One clear broth?
Shure: 啊不是
Shure: No.
Shure: 就是菌只有菌汤的
Shure: There's only mushroom broth.
Tasha: 只有菌汤
Tasha: Only mushroom broth.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 要不就一个纯辣的
Shure: Maybe we can have one spicy.
Shure: 然后一个那什么的
Shure: And one something else.
Tasha: 行
Tasha: Okay.
Shure: 但是有那么多电磁炉吗
Shure: But do we have enough induction cookers?
Tasha: 要不要洗一下
Tasha: Should we wash it?
Tasha: 电磁炉哪儿有电磁炉
Tasha: Where's the induction cooker?
Shure: 这儿好像有的有的
Shure: I think there are some here.
Tasha: 这有有两个
Tasha: There are two here.
Tasha: 还楼上还有个卡式炉呢所以够
Tasha: And there's a cassette stove upstairs, so it's enough.
Shure: 行那你拿一个电磁炉吧
Shure: Alright, then take one induction cooker.
Shure: 你拿着这个我拿
Shure: You take this, I'll take...
Tasha: 呃我我还要拿食材
Tasha: Uh, I still need to get the ingredients.
Shure: 哦好那先先上去一趟
Shure: Okay, then let's go upstairs first.
Tasha: 楼上有一个卡式炉
Tasha: There's a portable stove upstairs.
Tasha: 再拿一个电磁炉就行
Tasha: Just get an induction cooker too.
Shure: 好的
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 你在干什么
Shure: What are you doing?
Jake:监工
Jake: Supervising.
Jake:给他加油打气
Jake: Giving him some encouragement.
Shure: 监工导数据是吗
Shure: Supervising director, huh?
Shure: 好
Shure: Alright.
Shure: 插排拿过来
Shure: Bring the power strip over.
Shure: 插排不够长吧
Shure: The power strip isn't long enough, right?
Shure: 够吗
Shure: Is it enough?
Shure: 插排不够长
Shure: The power strip's not long enough.
Shure: 再接个插排
Shure: Add another power strip.
Jake:插牌不够长
Jake: The power strip's not long enough.
Jake:再接呗再接一个
Jake: Just add another one.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Shure: 排接排
Shure: Strip after strip.